تخلى عن الانحياد العسكري الذي تبنته
فنلندا لعقود يضيف عضوا جديدا لحلف النيتو
لتصبح ما مجموعه احدى وثلاثون دوله حدود
تشاركها فنلندا مع روسيا بطول 1300
كيلومتر لم تعد حدود حياد بل جبهه شماليه
لحلف النيتو وجبهه اقوى لتتشارك روسيا
الان
2600 كلم مع اربع من دول الحلف
قوه اضافيه كسبها الحلف فبالرغم من حيادها
لم تخفض فنلندا ميزانيه الدفاع منذ الحرب
البارده ليتحول بحر البلطيق الى منطقه
نفود للنيتو بانتظار انضمام السويد التي
تواجه مشكله مع تركيا خطوه ستزيد من عدد
قوات الحلف المنتشره شرق اوروبا تحديدا
على الحدود المشتركه مع روسيا الى ما
يقارب 300 الف جندي ما قد تراه موسكو
التصعيدا يدفعها الى فعل مماثل بعسكره
حدودها وهو ما بدا جليا في تصريحات
الكريملين
يرى الكرملين ان ذلك تفاقم اخر للوضع
وانها توسع النيتو تعد على امننا ومصالح
روسيا الاتحاديه ننظر الى ذلك بهذه
الطريقه بالضبط وسنتخذ تدابير مضاده لضمان
امننا التكتيكي والاستراتيجي باب يتركه
حلف النيتو مفتوحا رغم التهديدات الروسيه
لتمر عبره السويد قريبا وربما اوكرانيا
لاحقا ما قد يفجر غضبا روسيا من نوع جديد
او يضع حدا لطموح موسكو التوسعي الى عمر
العربيه